la campagne présidentielle en posant
dans des bas tout de suite et je vous
présente mes invités françoise gatel
bonsoir sénatrice union centriste d'ille
et vilaine pascal perrineau politologue
au soir parce qu'il ya le professeur des
universités à sciences po pire adrien
bartoli bonsoir directeur des études
politiques chez harris interactive et
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique toujours à mes côtés pour ce
second débat
l'une des informations de l'après midi
je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
l'annulation de ce meeting d'entrer en
campagne en tout cas elle était prévu
comme tel des manuels macron françoise
gatel il va quand même devoir se
déclarer avant d'aller à la date limite
le président c'est vendredi si je ne me
trompe pas ce que vous dites est une
vérité absolue mais il son calendrier et
ça n'échappe à personne totalement
bouleversé par ce qui se passe je pense
qu'il doit y avoir une recherche de
timing est sans doute que ce sera une
annonce des plus frugale oui là quelle
forme ça peut prendre
il faudra qu'ils adoptent une forme
sobre 1 on imagine qu'un mélange
d'audiovisuel
nationale et de presse locale soit le
mélange
peut-être le plus le plus idoine le plus
adapté 1 mais on voit bien très de
manière évidente il est obligé de
respecter les échéances bien sûr faut
pas qu'il manque le coche
mais cette campagne est une campagne qui
fonctionne au cul par dessus tête voyons
revenir en détail mais si on pousse la
la la réflexion jusqu'à l'absurde il n'y
aurait pas cette obligation de se
déclarer avant vendredi ça se trouve il
au louis l'apprendre il attendrait le
tout dernier moment parce que
certainement il a d'autres chats à
fouetter il est président en plus de ça
de l'union européenne d'autre part il a
une conception très active de son rôle à
la fois en tant que président de la
république française et président de
l'union européenne et donc oui s'il n'y
avait pas ce cette barrière ça serait
tout début avril l'annoncé de la
candidature adrien bartoli vous vous
venez de sortir un dernier baromètre sur
les intentions de vote alors c'est
intéressant parce qu'il a été réalisé ce
week-end donc après l'entrée en guerre
de de la russie à la nation de l'ukraine
et ce sondage ce beau remettre place
emmanuel macron largement en tête des
intentions de vote au premier tour oui
toujours en tête parce que pour le coup
il est depuis les mois hélas ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que l'arrière 27
% donc ça fait 3 points de plus en une
semaine ce qu'on avait pas vu comme aux
pour le président de la république à ce
stade c'est pas très surprenant quand on
les interroge sur d'autres aspects c'est
à dire est ce qui est gère bien la crise
il fait président français sont plutôt
positifs ne disent pas échec de la
diplomatie préalable non ils nous disent
ils donc il fait ce qu'il peut et biella
notamment pour nous protéger donc le
discours est assez laudateurs et puis
deuxièmement qu'on le voie d'une manière
générale en cas de crise généralement
les français se regroupent autour du
président de la république rarement
aussi proche d'une élection
présidentielle dont on le voit plutôt
dans les cotes de confiance entre les
cotes de popularité mais à chaque fois
on a un boost de 5 à 10 points pour le
président en place est là on le voit
dans le cas des intentions de vote parce
que l'élection est très proche si on
regarde la suite des autres candidats on
a vu les chiffres apparaître on a une
marine le pen à 18 eric zemmour à 15
jean luc mélenchon douze ennemis valérie
pécresse qui est maintenant en cinquième
position avec avec 11% des intentions de
vote pascal perrineau il ya
va on va élargir au delà de duca macron
est-ce qu'il ya certains candidats qui
sont moins impacté que d'autre part
cette entrée en guerre oui pour
l'instant on pouvait se dire et on l'a
dit à de très nombreuses reprises que
tous les candidats poutine au
compatibles ou anciens adorateurs parce
qu'il est difficile d'adorer aujourd'hui
vladimir poutine mais les anciens
adorateurs de vladimir poutine aurait pu
connaître une érosion forte ça n'est pas
le cas pour marine le pen ça n'est pas
le cas pour jean luc mélenchon
c'est vrai que la dynamique haussière de
zemmour semble un peu se calmer mais au
fond c'est plutôt quand on regarde les
données harris c'est plutôt valérie
pécresse qui pâtit de la situation
actuelle elle continue sa tendance
baissière et surtout la reprise du
président mal
entame son propre électorat parce que ce
sont des électorats au fond assez proche
parent sont des électorats les gens me
disent non de gouvernement
légitimiste donc qu'il y ait des
transferts entre les deux n'est pas
tellement étonnant matthieu croissandeau
cette campagne on peut on pourrait
presque se demander si elle va finir par
avoir lieu elle a recommencé un
couinement des passionnent guère les
français mais on connaît les prétendants
depuis le mois de décembre la plupart
d'entre eux ont commencé à dévoiler leur
projet a décliné des mesures il bat la
campagne et le tiennent des meetings il
passe des grands oraux devant des
associations des syndicats alors tous
tous tous les prétendants sauf un ont
l'a rappelé le président sortant qui lui
a préféré pour des raisons tactiques
jouer la montre expliquant qu'il
entendait bien présider jusqu'au dernier
quart d'heure
comme si c'était la question font comme
si c'était le premier président sortant
confronté au cas d'une réélection est
évidemment faux président et jusqu'au
dernier quart d'heure ça empêche pas de
faire campagne et se représenter or nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une situation
inédite cas avec la crise ukrainienne le
voilà aujourd'hui quasi empêcher de
faire campagne entre deux conseils de
défense de goût de filao de nuire
poutine ou à zelensky on voit mal en
effet comment ils trouveraient le temps
alors qu'ils assurent vous n'avez
rappelé la présence de l'union
européenne mais elle organiser les
réunions publiques de s'offrir des bains
de foule le principe ya des missions ou
tout simplement tirer les leçons du
quinquennat qui s'achève et d'expliquer
aux français pourquoi il en briguant un
second alors le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent a voulu
rassurer
ceux qui redoutent une élection sans
débat sans confrontation on écoute tout
de suite ne se passera pas d'un débat
démocratique le débat démocratique il
est indispensable élection
présidentielle c'est une échéance
démocratique majeur pour notre pays il y
aura un débat il y aura une
confrontation projet attend des ogec si
vous me demandez si on considère que
cette élection présidentielle le débat
qui doit avoir lieu peut-être escamoté
ou enjamber la réponse est non la
réponse est non et on trouvera les
moyens et quand je dis qu'on sait
l'ensemble des forces politiques que ce
débat puisse se tenir wayne on se
demande quand même s'il se fout pas
parce que il reste que 40 est un joueur
essentiel afin de 1er tour il va falloir
autant attendre encore quelques jours
avant qu'ivan macro ne se déclare et
ensuite parce qu'au fond six ans de la
vérité le chef de l'état aura tout fait
pour éviter la confrontation président
en surplomb il a jamais voulu être un
candidat comme les autres préférant
laisser série vont se déchirer en en
cuir conduisait les affaires du pays
mais faute d'avoir présenté le début du
commencement d'un projet il est en train
de transformer l'élection présidentielle
en casting sur le modèle du stop ou
encore avec ennui la certitude que les
français se demanderont qui au fond est
le plus capable quand ils sont dans
l'isoloir et qu'ils y seront dans l'urne
un bulletin un butin parlant au nom des
modèles marquants les stratèges de
l'elysée ont regardé deux modèles la
réélection d'obama la rédaction de marca
les izbas et pas de programme ils sont
faire élire ça se passe comme ça c'est
une habileté tactique qui peut lui
faciliter la tâche pour se faire élire
mais elle lui compliquera peut-être la
vie pour les cinq années qui viennent
pourquoi parce que au-delà de la
dimension personnelle du candidat le
projet c'est ce qui permet de constituer
une majorité de mener une politique de
fixer un cap ensuite parce que
si vous n'avez pas de confrontation sur
le projet avant vous pouvez très bien
avoir une confrontation sur le projet
après la légitimité se fait sur la
personnalité du président et pas sur le
projet qu'il a fixés et dans une france
qui est particulièrement divisée on le
sait par les crises qu'elle a subis que
ce soit et crise sociale une crise
sanitaire eh ben on sait que le feu coup
et puis enfin parce que se joue dans le
prochain mandat d' emmanuel macron la
survie de son mouvement si jamais les
rayures il n'a pas de parti n'a pas
d'assise et éditeurs il a pas d' assises
territoriales pardon il a pas
d'idéologie clairement défini qu'est ce
que ma chronique personne n'est encore
capable de bien le dire cinq ans après
et bien il a fédéré autour de lui
pendant son premier quinquennat un
attelage composite qui avaient les yeux
rivés sur la réélection du président
macro qui faisaient autorité le jour où
il sera réélu ça sera son dernier mandat
il aura plus la même autorité et alors
là chacun pensera la suite françoise
gatel ça veut dire que peut-être la
vraie campagne elle aura lieu pour les
législatives est-ce qu'on pourrait se
dire ça je partage ce que vous dite sur
cette campagne un peu étrange quand on
sait pas si c'est une campagne sauf qu
effectivement les candidats qui sont
déclarés rencontre des tas de lobby
d'association voire et que le président
il est comme suspendu enfin où nous
sommes suspendus à sa déclaration mais
sincèrement moi dans mon département
dilemme j'entends très peu parlé de la
campagne présidentielle parce que les
gens sont encore sous le poids de cette
crise sanitaire très dur le pouvoir
d'achat donc les gens ont l'impression
que c'est quelque chose qui intéresse un
microcosme donc là les choses vont être
un peu particulier alors souvent je
pense que enfin moi je sais pas comment
macron va faire campagne c'est un peu
étrange lui-même de temps sans doute est
en train de se demander la forme que ça
va prendre mais de toute façon aussi
emmanuel macron est élu je pense
indépendant indépendamment de cette
crise avec le rss enfin où moi je
l'appelle comme ça carrément poutine bah
oui enfin je lis
quand même assez soviétique
voilà et qu' on ne sait pas comment
cette guerre va évoluer parce que les
choses peuvent évoluer dans les jours et
dans les semaines qui viennent mais
indépendamment des crises extérieures je
pense qu'au niveau national
vous l'avez dit ce sera le deuxième
quinquennat du président macro s'il
l'était lui que son mouvement n'est pas
vraiment cimenté on va dire et que donc
cela fragil quoi cela veut dire qu'à
gauche comme à droite il va y avoir de
la recomposition parce que ça une
compliqué pour les républicains
compliqué pour les socialistes et je
pense que la crise sociale qu'on a connu
à travers les gilet jaune de reporter
son sonné alors je repose la même
question si vous n'avez pas tout à fait
incongru mais aussi votre réponse était
très intéressante sur l'hélice l'atvs
parce que il ya quand même ça ça va si
on imagine il peut encore se passer
beaucoup de choses mais un emmanuel
macron réélu et avoir un enjeu au tour
des législatives et de sa capacité à
avoir une majorité à construire une
majorité pascal perrineau oui mais vous
savez le quinquennat et l'inversion du
calendrier
un jour servis le président semble
transformer les élections du cela ti vct
élections législatives devient une
élection qui est fait presque en
catimini dans l'ombre de l'élection
présidentielle et le temps n'est pas si
on a été privé de campagne
continuera
si le conflit dure on continuera elle
privée et je crois plutôt sur le
scénario après oui après plusieurs mois
là les français pourront se dire mon a
été privé de plusieurs campagnes
électorales on n'a pas pu exprimer notre
volonté en totale libérée quelque part
une fois de plus comme en 2017 on peut
avoir l'impression en 2007 c'était
surtout le peuple de droite qui avait
l'impression d'avoir été privé de la
victoire qu'il attendait là ça dépassera
très nettement le peuple de droite on
aura une à satisfaction beaucoup plus
large et on peut avoir un troisième tour
lors du début du quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron qui sera jallet dur rugueux mais
si on continue les uns les autres de
faire comme si le l'élection était déjà
joué on va avoir une attention majeure
lelangue il
parce que c'est vrai que à la fois les
ce que vaut institut nous disent et
puisque les voilà les les experts les
analystes peuvent peuvent abonder ça ça
risque de provoquer une abstention
record ce que vous êtes des rues
accessibles aux six sur versailles pour
le crew de mesure depuis longtemps après
encore pire c'est sûr nous nous faire
actuellement la mesure autour de 68 % ce
qui serait quand même vrai abstention
record pour l'artiste une participation
participation bien sûr oui
présidentielle c'est la fête et très peu
élections pour une présidentielle après
ce qu'on voit actuellement c'est la
suite logique de ce qu'on a vu depuis
des mois c'est à dire que cette absence
de campagne campagne entre deux monts la
voix depuis des mois cette
cristallisation des électeurs autour de
candidats qui leur ressemble sans
vraiment connaître ce qu'ils peuvent
donner andreu le cadre d'un débat ou
d'un affrontement de programme on le
voit depuis des mois et on a des gens
qui au fond aujourd'hui sont les moins
intéressés à la campagne de ce qu'on a
mesurée depuis des années donc une
intérêt pour ceux qui se masquent est
quand même très faible des gens qui ont
une attention centré sur autre chose
hier le président aujourd'hui ces
événements en ukraine qui pèse très
lourdement dans le l'esprit des français
ollie d'ailleurs est ce qu'ils disent
pardon dans un service qui est ce qu'ils
disent les français que vous avez
interrogé pour ce baromètre que alors je
pars pas du dernier sondage part d'un
baromètre que vous avez fait pour le
groupe m6 rtl sur la perception de la
ddt du conflit par les français est ce
qu'ils disent que ce conflit va
influencer leur vote où on pas eu nous
disent oui c'est à dire qu'on a à peu
près deux tiers des français qui nous
disent ces événements vont avoir un
effet sur notre vote et ça serait partie
bien d'ailleurs sur tous les candidats
alors après il faut le mettre en
relative s'il ya d'autres enjeux qui
vont impacter les campagnes tout va pas
se faire autour de ça en revanche qui
est vrai c'est que le premier impact
c'est retarder l'entrée en campagne du
président de la république donc le
l'éventuelle débat qui peut se faire et
en parallèle et c'est ce qu'on est en
train de voir des électeurs qui
s'étaient portés sur un candidat qui
leur semblaient les plus proches de
leurs idées mais qui n'était pas sur
jusqu'à présent et qui se disent dans
les dernières semaines on peut plus
changer désormais on l'a choisi on va
aller jusqu'au bout et donc ça se
cristallise autour de ces quelques
candidats que sont emmanuel macron qui
ne l'est pas encore eric zemmour marine
le pen d'un côté et un petit peu jean
luc mélenchon ce qui est assez nouveau
dans ce qu'on mesure dans notre enquête
oui c'est plutôt en train de progresser
exactement faut pas se tromper ce qui se
pose c'est une question de légitimité au
président et c'est aussi une problème
démocratique il faut le dire parce que
se faire élire président sans avoir
c'est pas une affaire de publier son
programme c'est pas juste publié un
tract avec je vais faire c'est dit
mesure où c'est sans mesure c est d
avoir confronté d avoir débattu avec
d'autres cd avoir argumenté pour que ça
puisse se permettre aux français de se
faire une idée mais quand vous n'avez
pas ça va se pose également la question
de la légitime de la légitimité la
dernière fois il avait quand même une
vision aux mains des macros on était
pour on était content mais il avait une
vision il avait un projet et puis il ya
cette légitimité elle a été renforcé par
le vote aux législatives que ses
adversaires oublie souvent de rappeler
ou à une majorité écrasante et puis
ensuite même pas un sentiment diffus
dans l'opinion qui était on va lui
donner sa chance eh bien on l'a élu il
est là moi pas le juger tout de suite on
va attendre de voir de le juger sur
pièce aujourd'hui les français l'ont
déjà juger sur pièce et donc je pense
que la rentrée si ce débat si cet effort
de pédagogie c'était fort de conviction
cet effort d'adhésion une élection c'est
pas une tacite reconduction
il faut quand même il faut il faut une
adhésion et s'il n'y a pas cet effort là
mais si jamais il est réélu ça sera ça
sera on a eu beau très très compliqué
pour lui cet après midi les candidats
étaient convoqués à matignon l'occasion
pour yannick jadot de alors réclamé des
sanctions contre la biélorussie exr je
vous le rappel de base arrière aux
soldats russes
le candidat europe écologie verts qui
demande aussi de la transparence sur les
armes que la france va livrer à
l'ukraine c'était ce matin sur france
info les françaises et les français sont
en voie de savoir le type d'armes de
défense que nous envoyons à l'ukraine
j'ai dit je soutiens et j'ai été un des
premiers à demander ce type d'envoi mais
on voit tous les gouvernements et pour
l'instant quelle elle doit tous les pays
européens et je pense que c'est un
exercice normal de transparence dire
voilà nous envoyons des fusils des
munitions du carburant des armes
antichars la rolls des zips à votre avis
écoutez je poserai la question premier
ministre alors ça vous fait tiquer tout
se gâte est pourquoi je trouve la
question totalement totalement baroque
enfin je veux dire monsieur jadot et
peut-être un expert militaire il va
apprécier
la qualité du physique qu'on va envoyer
et puis cette exigence de transparence
c'est totalement hors sujet avec quoi ce
qui est important c'est qu'effectivement
la transparence je trouve qu'elle est là
c'est à dire qu'on dise qu'on va aller
soutenir l'europe en plus ce qui est
assez formidable valises soutenir et
donner des armes défensives ce sont des
armes défensives à l'ukraine qui est
agressé monsieur jeannot enfin il y là
j'ai dit franchement je trouve qu'il
n'est pas au niveau du tout la même
c'est surtout vladimir poutine n'attend
que ça qu'on lui donne la liste du modem
en froid et surtout le même
l'acheminement par aux rapaces et ils se
tapent sur sans doute par la pologne en
tout cas la pologne a dit qu'elle était
prête à servir de base arrière pour
transmettre
césar mais il ya un autre symptôme de
cette campagne en possède deux campagnes
c'est la question des parrainages
françoise gatel j'aimerais vous entendre
parce que vous étiez plutôt favorable à
l'initiative de françois bayrou aux
éléments de banques des parrainages et
est-ce que vous avez changé d'avis vous
en ai tout à l'aune de ce de ce conflit
alors j'ai trouvé l'initiative de de
françois bayrou intéressantes comme
celle de david lisnard parce que moi
j'étais vraiment très en colère de voir
le harcèlement et la culpabilisation
dont faisait l'objet les maires je lire
c'est mal connaître ce qui se passe dans
les communes de france où très souvent
dans la plupart entre cahier des équipes
composite de gens qui se réunissent sur
un projet communal mais qui ne parlent
jamais de politique au sein du conseil
municipal et que le maire ne peut pas
s'affranchir de l'appartenance à une
équipe et assure un parrainage a
fortiori pour un candidat d'extrême
c'est compliqué et la population vit
souvent très mal ça parce qu'ils ont
l'impression de de se voir coller une
étiquette donc ça m'a profondément agacé
et j'ai trouvé l'initiative de françois
bayrou intéressante parce que en même
temps que je dis ça on a un vrai
problème avec des candidats qui
représente un certain nombre de wafa
marine le pen
j'aime tourner des présidentielles elle
à elle apporté un certain nombre de voix
et que empêcher des candidats de se
présenter c'est un sujet dont moi j'ai
été sincèrement prête à participer est
ce que oui et je ne le ferai pas
pourquoi je ne le ferai pas à cause de
la situation internationale en ukraine
parce que même si je pense qu'on va
permettre dans une démocratie que chacun
puisse exprimer comme voltaire qui
disait je ferai tout pour que vous
puissiez parler même si je suis pas
d'accord avec vous j'ai aujourd'hui
moi j'ai entendu et j'ai lu la fiction
quand mélenchon pourrait porter à
certaines personnalités politiques j'ai
entendu marine le pen les émaux je veux
dire aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation assez leur soutien passé de
poutine que oui mais aujourd'hui ça
reste quand même enfin leur discours est
un peu limite alors qu'on est bien dans
une agression me guerrière d'un pays par
un état qui l'a décidé tout seul et je
pense que là mon attachement ou non
respect de la démocratie et un peuvent
enfin et même très freiné par rapport à
ces candidats alors je voulais vous nous
disiez ça parce que on va pendant
quelques minutes se concentrait
justement sur ces candidats qui avaient
affiché vous en parliez tout à l'heure
pascal perrineau voilà une parfois une
admiration pour vladimir poutine et
notamment eric zemmour il était ce matin
sur rtl et face notamment aux
journalistes alba ventura et françois
lenglet écouter la séquence est vraiment
intéressante il lui demande si vladimir
poutine est un démocrate ne dit rien
c'est un démocrate autoritaire moi je
vous répète ce que j'ai dit démocrate
autoritaire où il rien dire ah ça veut
tout dire à rien absolument tout ah si
ça veut dire qu'ils démocrate il est élu
par le peuple enfin ici n'est pas c'est
pas le peuple peuple n'a pas voté contre
lui ça sans rien ça veut dire qu'ils
utilisent des méthodes que nous
n'utiliserons pas parce que je le répète
depuis le début je suis français je ne
suis pas russe et donc la russie n'a pas
la même histoire ça vous a pas échappé
que
art faisait assassiner l'europe oilers
opposants dans la cour un cas la cour ce
que ne faisait pas les rois français
difficile de renoncer aux louanges
tressées
président russe pendant des années c'est
quand même le sentiment qu'on a parce
que bien sûr dans cette notion étrange
démocrates aux
démocrates autoritaire on voit bien que
c'est pas avant tout un autoritarisme
c'était comme jadis on parlait lurs tout
à l'heure les fameuses démocratie
populaire a envoyé assez peu la
démocratie ayant été renvoyé à ses peut
aussi le peuple qui étaient sous le joug
du parti communiste normes on voit bien
la fascination si vous voulez dans une
partie du personnel politique français
pour ce qu'on a appelé les démocraties
libérales
les fameuses démocratie libérale dont le
modèle est un peu monsieur or ban
hongrie mais au delà pourquoi pas
erdogan en turquie voilà on voit très
bien comment peu à peu cette notion de
démocratie libérale vient mettre à bas
la démocratie à laquelle nous étions
jusque alors tous très attachés c'est à
dire une démocratie pluraliste
libéral politiquement et qui respectait
la séparation des pouvoirs et qui ne
cherchaient pas par exemple à mettre la
justice constitutionnelle sous le joug
du pouvoir exécutif comme ça a été le
cas en pologne ou anglais comme un cran
une différence ou démocratie libérale
vous devez appeler ça remet en cause les
stades l'état de droit et remet en cause
la libre expression des tonga presse et
puis
et puis ça remet en cause l'action des
ong
de tout ce qui peut émerger comme
contre-pouvoir chez vladimir poutine et
dieu sait qu sorbonne n'est pas un
tendre mais on en prison fait
emprisonner des opposants ont un goût on
assassine les opposants on a des
élections qui sont soviétique pour mon
propre fille expression gérant dit pas
on n'est pas dans une heure dans une
démocratie abouti
pierre-adrien bartoli parce qu'elle
prenne un peu évoqué tout à l'heure mais
je voudrais savoir si vous l'avez
évaluer est ce que oui ou non c'est ses
amitiés russe pèse sur les intentions de
vote d'un eric zemmour par exemple ou
alors est pas du tout elle pèse pas très
fort on voit une baisse de 0,5 point
cette semaine mais qui au final n'est
pas une marque très ferme ce qu'on voit
en revanche c'est une vraie division
alors qu'on voit sur d'autres enjeux
sociologiques notamment entre
l'électorat de marine le pen et les bras
d'eric zemmour
l'électorat d'eric zemmour c'est un
électorat qui au fond considère plus que
les autres et plus que l'électorat de
marine le pen que la france est la
france la russie c'est la russie qui se
sentent moins solidaire avec le peuple
ukrainien aujourd'hui qu'ils ont moins
envie qu'on intervienne d'une manière ou
d'une autre et qui au fond sont pas
exactement sur la ligne qui est porté
par eric zemmour mais elle s'en
rapproche un petit peu al'inverse on a
des électeurs marine le pen qui eux sont
beaucoup plus ouverts entre guillemets
vis-à-vis du peuple ukrainien vis-à-vis
de ce qui se passe qui sont beaucoup
plus favorables notamment à l'accueil de
réfugiés ukrainien en france ce qui est
beaucoup moins le cas des électeurs eric
zemmour est donc on a une vraie ligne de
partage entre les deux pour l'instant ça
certes plus tôt marine le pen sur une
ligne d'apaisement qu'elle porte depuis
plusieurs mois dans la campagne qu'eric
zemmour qui se voit légèrement reculé
dans cette intention de vote mais soyons
clairs les deux sont en train de
cristalliser leur électorat qui comme on
vient de le voir sont deux électorats
différents et probablement qu'une bonne
partie des électorats irons jusqu'au
bout avec leur candidat désormais et
quand on vous avez choix il va lever sa
le seul à la question de la
responsabilité de cette cette guerre en
fonction de du candidat soutenus on
trouve d'autres responsables que weimer
coating c'est ça c'est exactement ça on
a vraiment en france alors à droite et
là on a ces différences entre les
électeurs de marine le pen les écarts
d'eric zemmour des électeurs d'eric
zemmour qui disent oui la nicotine est
responsable mais l'otan aussi on est on
retrouve de manière presque analogue la
même logique à la gauche de la gauche
chez les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
ils sont les deux électorats qui me
disent évidemment là des meilleures
poutines et la personne qui a déclenché
cette bière et c'est lui le principal
responsable mais n'oublions pas la
responsabilité des occidentaux et
notamment de l'otan dans cette affaire
c'est beaucoup moins le cas dans tous
les autres électorat est sacré justement
une différence de perception
alors il ya des candidats évidemment qui
tente de reprendre l'initiative alors il
y en a deux qui ont la même idée ou
presque valérie pécresse et eric zemmour
valérie pécresse un tweet voilà ce
qu'elle dit je me suis entretenu ce
week-end à deux reprises avec le
président nicolas sarkozy sur la
situation et chrétienne je propose que
la france et l'union européenne le
désigne comme médiateur européen pour
l'ukraine eric zemmour va un peu plus
loin puisqu'il propose deux émissaires
toujours nicolas sarkozy mais aussi
l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères hubert védrine un écouteur
examens devront tout faire aujourd'hui
pour
apaiser le jeu pour favoriser les
négociations entre l'ukraine et la
russie vous voyez que j'ai proposé hier
d'envoyer deux émissaires français
respecté par les deux protagonistes
monsieur sarkozy qui avait négocié
l'arrêt des hostilités en géorgie il y a
plus de dix ans et monsieur védrine qui
fut ministre des affaires étrangères
français qui est respecté par la russie
pour pour pour essayer de trouver une
solution j'ai vu d'ailleurs avec plaisir
que quelques heures plus tard madame
pécresse soutenait cette initiative
la réponse du berger drine ça tient en
deux mots c'est idiot voilà il n'y a pas
de réaction d'un col à sarkozy françoise
gatel vous êtes sénatrice sud et vous
soutenez valérie pécresse lady soutien à
valérie pécresse s'est il ya une petite
nuance sémantique dans ce combat je vous
parle le français ouais
moi je me suis dit quelle mouche l'a
piqué valérie pécresse avec cette
proposition nicolas sarkozy émissaires
européens et vous je veux dire tout ce
qui peut contribuer à trouver des
solutions pas de prix - je dirais c'est
étonnant que enfin c'est pas étonnant
que monsieur zemmour par exemple site de
français parce que je pense qu'il ignore
un peu lente je trouve que si on négocie
c'est au titre de l'europe et que dans
ce cas il aurait fallu évoquer d'autres
non et à ce moment là pourquoi pas
madame merkel moi je trouve que c'est
une idée un peu étrange de mettre des
émissaires quand on a une union
européenne avec une présidence et en
plus une union européenne qui de manière
jose padilla inattendu mais que je
trouve absolument formidable est en
train de se fortifier parce qu'on est en
pleine crise donc c'est pas mal bon jeu
je pense que vous voyez on est aussi par
rapport à la question que vous posez
chaque pays c'est d'exister dans un
moment où seul le président émerge donc
chacun y va de sa contribution il c'est
de dire des choses j'ai vu la chose
anachronique de monsieur jacques duhault
là on parle d'émissaires voilà je pense
que chacun
dont c'est symptomatique oui c'est
simplement d'exister dans un comté il ya
un peu parfois que tu est dérisoire
enfin quand on écoute monsieur et mots
proposés deux émissaires français où se
dit mais c'est pas vrai quoi c'est pas
possible mais valérie mais je vous fais
un peu faisandée joue à être président
voit on a l'impression que voilà vous
chercher absolument les attributs
extérieurs de la présidentialité sans
réellement me l'ait trouvée parce que si
on se pose la question d'avoir des
hommes et des femmes qui au nom de
l'union européenne resterai
dans une logique de compromis il
faudrait absolument qu'il y à un
allemand parce que je ne sais pas ce
qu'ils font quand même regarder ce qui
se passe en ce moment la grande
nouveauté c'est le changement de cap de
l'allemagne sur s'est absolument
extraordinaire aux normes ça va changer
la face de l'europe et ça va changer
véritablement ce que en impression dans
trois jours on a plus fait pour l'avancé
sur le terrain international et de la
défense qu'en 30 ans presque d'europe 1
donc vous laisse y avait deux émissaires
il faudrait vraiment un allemand et je
partage tout à fait le diagnostic
d'hubert védrine c'est idiot
c'est clair on va on va parler
maintenant de d'une question qui est
quand même qu'on est obligé de se poser
avec marion migros qui doit être pas
loin voilà marion bonsoir bienvenue la
question d'un report éventuel de cette
élection présidentielle est ce que ça
peut être envisagée alors effectivement
c'est une question qui se pose
aujourd'hui mais qui ne s'était
finalement jamais posée dans l'histoire
de la vème république jusque l'épidémie
de coville qui a donc rebattu les cartes
souvenez-vous à l'époque en mars 2020 le
second tour des élections municipales
est exceptionnellement reportée au 28
juin 2020 un choix rendu possible par le
fait que ce scrutin peut être modifiée
par un simple projet de loi ce n'est pas
le cas d'élection présidentielle dont
les règles sont inscrits dans la
constitution et dans cette constitution
la guerre n'est pas un motif de report
de scrutin ce que alors quels sont les
motifs que le prévoit leur premier cas
de figure la constitution l'autorisent
si un candidat officiel moeurs ou s'il
est dans l'incapacité de se présenter
deuxième cas de figure un scrutin peut
être reporté si on reste dans le laps de
temps suivant entre 20 et 35 jours avant
l'expiration du mandat présidentiel
prévu ici au 13 mai 2022 c'est à dire
que le gouvernement par simple décret
peut décider de retarder de quelques
jours ou de quelques semaines à
l'élection n'est donc pas au delà du 13
mai enfin dernière possibilité
reporter l'élection présidentielle pour
reporter l'élection présidentielle il
faudrait réviser la constitution
ah mais cela suppose l'adoption d'un
projet de loi constitutionnelle de façon
conforme entre à les deux assemblées
assemblée nationale et sénat puis par le
parlement réuni en congrès mais là aussi
il faut le faire avant l'élection ce qui
est de toute façon peu probable car la
france n'est pas directement menacée le
territoire n'est pas occupée et la
campagne présidentielle par exemple tout
de même à se poursuivre et écoutez à ce
sujet benjamin morel maître de
conférences en droit public le tribun
est insincère si jamais les électeurs
sont pas en capacité d'aller voter si en
effet on avait une partie du territoire
français qui était occupé par l'armée
russe et que dans ce territoire
l'élection ne pouvait pas avoir lieu là
en effet ça crée une distorsion
électorale si jamais on avait une partie
de nos concitoyens qui allait voter avec
un pistolet sur la tempe oui delà en
effet ce sera un sincère là en
l'occurrence il ya rien ensuite ça veut
peut poser un problème de légitimité
c'est à dire que si on a les manuels
macron qui est reconduit par défaut
parce qu'il n'y a pas vraiment eu de
campagne dans les médias exceptés rhin
et qu'au bout du compte bo normalement
les gens ne se sont pas trop pour qui
ils vont voter ben vont reconduire le
sortant on peut avoir ensuite des
mouvements diriger les jeunes qui
explosent en disant bah oui le président
n'a pas été réélu dans de bonnes
conditions mais ça c'est politique a
mesuré d'icm en parlant il n'y a donc
pas matière à la contention donnant à
contentieux dans ce scrutin et pour le
juriste jean philippe derosier si le
moindre événement d'ampleur devaient
conduire à engager le renvoi du scrutin
ce serait la porte ouverte à toutes les
manipulations ce dernier rappelle qu'il
dira le président s'est aussi élire le
chef des armées et ça prend tout son
sens en ce moment écoutez le l'élection
présidentielle c'est un acte
démocratique fondamental qui sert à
désigner notamment chef des armées
qu'est le président de la république et
qu'il s'agisse donc de reconduire celui
qui est actuellement en poste qui n'est
pas encore formellement candidats ou
qu'il s'agit d'élire un nouveau
président de la république et donc un
nouveau chef des armées il est
nécessaire que cet instant démocratique
puisse se dérouler au moment où il est
prévu afin de conférer à ce président
toute la légitimité dont il a besoin
pour
intervenir dans cette crise européenne
majeure que constitue cet acte
d'agression de la russie envers
l'ukraine est à noter un autre point à
prendre en compte le report de
l'élection obligerait également les
candidats rallonger leurs frais de
campagne et tout ce ne sont pas prêts ou
n'ont pas les moyens merci beaucoup
merci mario en vigueur pour ce point
précis pascal perrineau bon ça c'est
tout simplement impossible de c'est
impossible c'est impossible et c'est
tout le défi d'une démocratie de
respecter même dans les périodes
troublées
l'agenda ce qui est prévu
sinon ça serait l'aveu d'un signe de
fébrilité et de faiblesse il faut faire
confiance dans nos institutions tout
simplement je crois qu'elles ont montré
qu'elles étaient qu'elle était tout à
fait solide et capable de faire face à
des crises moi je partage ce que vous
dite c'est à dire parce que justement il
y a aussi un certain nombre de risques
et de dangers je crois qu'il faut garder
son sang froid en tout cas en l'état
actuel des choses il s'avère plus que
jamais je pense qu'il est nécessaire de
procéder aux élections la forme la crise
sanitaire où on s'inquiétait d'une
manière très importante et que il va y
avoir une question de légitimité du
président de la présidente élue s'il ya
une faible participation
donc moi je pense qu'il ne faut pas
rajouter de risque démocratique à ce
pays qui est quand même un peu on va
dire éparpillés comme un feu qui couve
en faisant attention et procédant aux
élections maintenant je comprends que
pour les candidats déclarés c'est
extrêmement difficile on a vu par leurs
suggestions qu'il faut qu'ils existent
donc il faut qu'ils proposent des choses
qu'ils ne feraient sans doute pas si la
campagne était ordinaire entre
guillemets autre chose que c'est un
exercice très difficile pour pour tous
tous les candidats et la difficulté que
l'on a aujourd'hui je trouve c'est qu'
il faudrait que l'un des candidats quel
qu'il soit organisé deux rencontres
comme l'avait vu charles de gaulle entre
le peuple et la sueur c'est reconnaît un
projet alors aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
ait beaucoup sur des thématiques un
certain nombre de propositions qui n'en
mène pas les gens alors qu'on est dans
un enfin en situation compliquée
difficile et je pense qu'il faut
raconter une histoire aux français il
s'agit pas de les faire rêver une
manière démesurée mais blanc donner de
l'espérance tu dire qu'il y a un avenir
de la solidarité et ça aujourd'hui on
s'en passe mais pourtant on est enfin
c'est une campagne on est face à des
choix qui sont des choix majeurs pour
les prochaines décennies
le giec a publié un nouveau rapport
aujourd'hui qui est alarmant pas sur ce
qui va se passer dans dix ans mais sur
ce qui les conséquences actuelles du
dérèglement climatique a déjà des choix
à faire sur le nucléaire on a entendu ce
que le président a proposé avec la
construction de 6 nouveaux réacteurs
pire adrien bartoli je me tourne vers
vous pour savoir si voilà ce qui
pourrait faire finalement le voilà le le
sel les dires d'une campagne et dans
ciel s'est totalement écrasée dans
l'opinion aujourd'hui par la guerre en
ukraine tout simplement certes y'a pas
d'autres thèmes qui peuvent émerger
d'autres thèmes peuvent émerger ont
émergé manière transverse au concept
2000 campagne qu'on est présent mais
effectivement oui les gens ont la tête à
autre chose c'est de lumière le vide
c'est aujourd'hui cette situation en
ukraine juste un point pour pour
rebondir ce qu'on voit dans les
intentions de vote aujourd'hui ce qu'on
a vu dans les élections intermédiaires
aussi rejoint deux indicateurs qu'on a
par ailleurs c'est à dire que si le plan
de la république devait être conduit ça
reste hypothétique il faudra quand même
se rappeler en termes de niveau de
confiance aujourd'hui dans l'opinion il
a plus de 50% donc ça reste un plutôt
bon niveau dans une france qui est même
plutôt emprise et que la défiance donc
il ya une forme de logique qui ce qui se
crée quand on voit les niveaux très
élevés vont faire ou peuvent faire les
candidats de la droite de la droite ça
fait écho avec ce qu'on peut mesurer par
ailleurs en termes de préoccupations
autour des enjeux migratoires ou tous
les enjeux de sécurité qui sont quand
même très présent quand on voit que tous
les candidats entre beaucoup de
candidats proposent de réindustrialiser
le pays et ce type de politique mais ça
fait etc ou encore une fois aux attentes
fortes qu'on mesure donc oui il y aura
un enjeu de à terme de d'adhésion et
d'absence potentiel de projets débattus
lors de l'élection présidentielle et il
y aura cette question de légitimité à
moyen terme mais en revanche l'élection
tourner quand même autour de candidats
autour de propositions qui tiennent le
haut du pavé dans les différentes
enquêtes qu'on peut faire ou
pascal perrineau je termine avec la
présidence française de l'union
européenne finalement qui qui devait
offrir à emmanuel macron la possibilité
d'exister aussi différemment et ce vent
de marque et de se différencier des
autres candidats dans cette campagne
dans les quatre premiers mois de la
campagne
finalement c'est à la fois un atout et
un risque aujourd'hui c'est un atout et
un risque en effet et c'est certainement
le leader européen le plus exposé
aujourd'hui personne n'est à l'abri en
effet d'un mauvais choix alors certains
lieux ou fait un mauvais procès faut
bien reconnaître d'avoir été rencontré
le président poutine ne pas avoir réussi
comment il avait essayé d'ailleurs les
français disent bah voila il avait
raison d'essayer qu'il soit de gauche de
droite ou d'ailleurs d'ailleurs il avait
raison d'essayer vous mieux épuisé
toutes les solutions diplomatiques avant
de soutenir l'effort l'effort de guerre
mais enfin ça lui donne une vie habilité
dans la campagne et ça vient gommer une
visibilité sur ce qui était sa force
avant quand vous regardiez les images
diffusées à la république là il y avait
une majorité de français qui disait il
représente bien les intérêts de la
france à l'étranger en revanche sur tout
ce qui était proximité avec les gens
d'en bas là il est faible et très faible
le premier trait d'image est en train de
gommer le second merci beaucoup à tous
d'avoir participé à à ce débat à cette
nouvelle édition spéciale de sens public
je vous dis à demain